welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the marvel cinematic universe
will always be a series revisited both
by hardcore fans and people who are
about to be but one question now arising
as those with idle time are putting
their disney plus subscriptions to good
use
is what is the best order to watch these
films now i've always felt that you
can't go wrong with release order
that's how dad did it that's how america
does it and it's worked out pretty good
so far
but let's be honest if marvel could end
game the timeline and release them all
again
would they really do it all in the same
order would kevin feige have followed
iron man
with ed norton hulk and then another
iron man movie would he release hulk at
all
the star wars franchise has its machete
rewatch order
so i think it is time we did the same
for a cinematic universe that actually
pulled off
masterful continuity and
interconnectivity i'm gonna present to
you new rockstar's official
mcu watch order and in case you don't
like it don't worry i got four of them
one of those let's just start with the
simple current release order
in the early years marvel studios
released films really according to like
hollywood studio clockwork which of
these titles will maximize profits based
on the hottest titles we currently got
the rights to
and sure filmmakers ended up minimizing
risk with ground-based battles
and then later had to kind of awkwardly
retcon things after recasting actors or
suddenly regaining the rights to certain
things
but all the foreshadowing and callbacks
and post-credit setups
all those tie-ins are what make the mcu
so great and they all really work in one
direction and that direction is the
historical release order so for
first-timers that's how the rest of us
consumed it and you have to eat your
veggies before the dessert too but uh
for the rest of us marvel's sweet tea
let's cut that wire our buddy hector
navarro proposed a solid watch order on
nerdist based on the chronology of the
latest set ending scene of a film
in order to best set up the next film so
while he sticks mostly to release order
he does rearrange some of the phase one
films and the phase three films between
civil war and infinity war definitely go
check out his list it's really good but
if we were to be true to the mcu
chronology
you really should take into account the
totality of the film's events so with
that in mind here is our
chronological order okay you start with
captain america the first avenger which
is set mostly in the 1940s then we move
on to captain marvel set mostly in 1995
and then you move on to iron man
followed by the rest of phase one which
all take place in the same one week
that's called fury's big week
iron man 2 ends by setting up the
question of hulk
so then we get incredible hulk and then
you get thor
whose post-credits scene sets up
avengers from there the chronology
follows release order you got iron man 3
then thor the dark world then captain
america the winter soldier
and then guardians of the galaxy but
since guardians volume 2 it's
technically
set two months after volume one that one
comes next
then he got age of ultron and then
ant-man and then civil war
but then spider-man homecoming
immediately follows civil war
since its events directly follow tony's
recruitment of peter
and deals with the aftermath of that and
then you watch doctor strange
which technically does begin before
civil war
but strange's bigger battles with like
the zealots dormammu the bulk of that
movie
that's all in the autumn after civil war
and after spider-man homecoming
okay next i would place black widow
since as of this taping we've been told
it's set in the two years between civil
war and infinity war
but then i would put black panther which
is also set sometime after civil war but
i prefer it as a kind of prelude
staging of the crucial battlefield of
infinity war setting up the earth side
of infinity war so that
next we could watch thor ragnarok as the
cosmic side set up to infinity war so
that after that you can watch infinity
war and then all the rest in release
order ant-man the wasp take out captain
marvel because we've already watched
that then end game and spider-man apart
from home now while this chronological
order leads with cap's origin
i believe it places too much emphasis on
captain marvel while marvel studios was
deliberate about nick fury naming the
avengers initiative after carol danvers
call sign it'd just be a bit weird to go
21 movies without another mention of
carol danvers or the scrolls
so for even more seasoned mcu watchers
us
uwatu level watchers here's another
option which i'm calling the
cosmic porter one that reframes the mcu
as the colorful intergalactic theme park
it eventually evolves into so the cosmic
order opens with
guardians of the galaxy which
establishes the infinity stones
backstory
and the infinity song is big bad thanos
in his whole long game
then next you would go right into
guardians vol 2 which builds on the
celestial mythology
and does hint at terra as a pale blue
dot
destination just part of this wide
universe and then following that mention
of celestials in the guardians movies
here would be where we insert the
eternals film which
explores the link between celestials and
ancient life on earth then following
that would be
thor exploring that link between the
science of earth and the magic of other
cosmic realms
then twist here you watch black panther
which if you think about it it's a
really interesting companion piece to
the royal brotherly drama of thor
and another story of how
extraterrestrial influences
ended up creating the most powerful
kingdom on earth like asgard wakanda is
a secret kingdom that debates on how
best to help humanity
and only then do we now move on to
captain america the first avenger
which shows how this cosmic tech was
resurrected
in the modern age tying it into world
war ii and then you watch captain marvel
which did secretly drag earth into the
intergalactic cree scroll war
and then now do we watch iron man and
iron man 2
which follows nick fury's initiative
establishing captain marvel
followed by incredible hulk really here
we're seeing the attempts and the
failures of earth's authorities trying
best to
prepare themselves for the coming wars
but then the cosmic dam bursts when we
watch
avengers and then in iron man 3 earth's
front man tony stark suffers wormhole
trauma
followed by wormhole double downs and
door the dark world
but then in doctor strange our next
watch we're reassured when some humans
are masters of portal control but then
as we move on earth's inner defenses
crumble when we watch captain america
winter soldier
age of ultron ant-man civil war and then
spider-man homecoming that would be
followed by a black widow presumably and
then with earth's defenses down
the cosmic consequences play out in
release order infinity war ant-man the
wasp setting up avengers end game and
then far from home
by reframing these events on a cosmic
scale yes this order does
delay tony stark's entrance but i would
argue it also elevates his heroism as an
unexpected latecomer
from c53 shocking the universe by saving
everyone and this order introduces the
infinity stones in the same order of
thanos acquisition of them
at the climax of the saga power space
reality
soul would be delayed because it doesn't
appear until infinity war time
and then mind well before i continue
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video
wow every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
it's sugar-free and has zero calories
yet it tastes great
purple there's over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those great
flavors is purple haze
it is the power and the color scheme of
the heart-shaped herb of wakanda
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order at bang
energy.com when you use the code
newrockstarts25 there you can buy cans
of bang energy including their sweet tea
and keto coffee flavors
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25 percent
off at bang
energy.com using the code newrockstars25
but all this said
i recognize that not everyone watches
the mcu through the same crazy
cross-eyed wide-angle lens that i do at
the end of the day this saga started and
ended with the daddy who loved us 3000
and there should be a watch order option
that reflects that
and so i propose to you new rockstars
definitive iron order
and of course we open the same way daddy
peggy did i am
iron man the story that started it all
but then we move on to the
foil equally at the heart of the series
captain america the first avenger
so we start with the two heroes at the
core of this infinity saga
but coming out of the first cap film we
then explore the consequences of super
soldier experimentation on earth
by thaddeus ross in the incredible hulk
but then before iron man 2
here i think would be a good place for
black widow now if the movie's events
are too explicitly post-civil war
it won't really work but really natasha
deserves to be among the first origin
stories
then we move on to iron man 2 which
perfectly sets up four
but then right before the avengers we
insert captain marvel because my
favorite thing about that movie is how
it's a nick fury origin story which
really does
lead up to the avengers and how he got
his hands on that tesseract okay so
after the avengers next is iron man 3.
but since that movie tricks us with a
fake mandarin i think it'd be cool to
follow this with the story of the true
mandarin in shang chi in the legend of
the 10 ranks but again that would really
only work if the movie's plot doesn't
focus
too much on the snap or the blip but
then next should be captain america
winter soldier because we would follow
the battle in new york with stark's
reaction so we need to check in with the
other hero the story captain america
and his reaction after nick fury opened
the pandora's box and broadened the
military industrial complex then next
we go to thor the dark world which given
eric selvig's obsession with
ancient ruins in that movie could set up
marvel's the eternals after that
and then all this collision of ancient
cosmic tech with earth
sets up the guardians of the galaxy
followed immediately by guardians of the
galaxy vol 2
the movies really are our best watch
back to back then we head back to earth
for age of ultron iron man's biggest
folly
but assuming marvel does intend to set
up an illuminati storyline based on that
iron man 2 easter egg we've been talking
about
i think after ultron would be a good
place for tony's intellectual equal to
be introduced
doctor strange the two minds most
important to defeating thanos later on
and then we watch ant-man leading to
scot's big role in civil war
and optionally if black widow does
reference of war a lot you could move it
here instead but then following civil
war should be the film's most centered
around the characters that we were most
curious about from that conflict
spider-man and spider-man homecoming
then black panther and then the movie
that explained where thor
and hulk were during civil war thor
ragnarok and ragnarok perfectly sets up
infinity war
then ant-man and the wasp and then iron
man's big sacrifice play in avengers end
game
and the battle over his legacy and there
you have it the iron order
which alongside the normal release order
the chronological order and the cosmic
order that gives you
four valid watch orders for the mcu each
with mixed pros and cons depending on
what you love about this saga the most
but note that in each of these i insist
that you watch all of them
because as awkward as the recasting is
in the first hulk movie it is still
part of the history but which watch
order do you prefer for the infinity
saga comment down below and join this
discussion on our official discord
server by becoming a patron
at patreon.com newrockstars follow me on
instagram at eavos follow me rockstars
and subscribe for
future watch orders once more movies
come out like my upcoming bossy wild
card order that like involves watching
in-game at the same time as avengers in
the dark world and guardians one
and then stopping and pausing different
windows of disney plus and crying the
throwbar more thor hasn't come out yet
[Music]
you